welcome to the show everybody lots of
big news to talk about including some
really important
um pharmaceutical developments as we
might call them Merck is now pushing
into the emergency use authorization
request phase a so-called covid pill
that they say based on their trials
reduces the risk of hospitalization and
death by about 50 percent now my view on
this has been that politics aside having
an effective treatment in addition to a
vaccine is a really great thing there's
a lot of people thinking about this in
the context of the unvaccinated well now
the unvaccinated don't have to worry
because they can take a pill if they get
the virus and it cuts risk of
hospitalization and death by 50 there
may be people that are going to think
about it that way uh but not me let's
talk about
um the developments and then we will go
from there Merck says covid pill Cuts
risk of death and hospitalization in a
potential Leap Forward in the global
fight against the pandemic drug maker
Merck said Friday that its experimental
pill for people sick with covet reduced
hospitalizations and deaths by half if
cleared by Regulators it would be the
first pill shown to treat covid-19
adding a whole new easy to use weapon
to an Arsenal that already includes the
vaccine the company said it will soon
ask Health officials in the U.S and
around the world to authorize the pill's
use a decision from the U.S Food and
Drug Administration could come within
weeks after that all other covid
treatments authorized in the U.S require
an IV or an injection a pill taken at
home by contrast Woody's pressure
pressure on hospitals and could also
help curb outbreaks in poorer and more
remote corners of the world that don't
have access to the more expensive
infusion therapies this would allow us
to treat many more people much more
quickly and we trust much less
expensively Merck and its partner
ridgeback Biotherapeutics as early said
early results showed patients who
received the drug
malnopiravir within five days of coveted
symptoms had about half the rate of
hospitalization and death as those who
received a dummy pill the placebo the
study tracked 775 adults with mild to
moderate covid considered high risk for
disease because of health problems like
obesity diabetes or heart disease the
results have not yet been reviewed by
outside experts the usual procedure for
vetting new medical research among
patients taking malnapirovir 7.3 percent
were either hospitalized or died at the
end of 30 days compared with 14 percent
of those getting the dummy pill that is
a significant reduction
after that time period there were no
deaths among those who received the drug
compared with eight deaths in the
placebo group this is one of those cases
we've talked about before medical ethics
when the test uh medication or procedure
seems to be working so well it becomes
unethical to keep people on the placebo
and in fact that's what they talk about
here the results were so strong that an
independent group of medical experts
monitoring the trial recommended
stopping it early Executives plan to
submit data to the FDA in the coming
days and experts stress the importance
of getting vaccinated anyway so again a
lot of people hearing this and saying
we've been saying there's going to be a
treatment of some kind we don't need to
get vaccinated that's not at all what
this is about my thinking is the
following math this is a great
additional layer in in addition to
vaccination we've talked so much about
you know I did what was available to me
I went and got the vaccine
and yet it's not a hundred percent no
vaccine is 100 and Immunity May Wane as
is often the case with vaccines we're
trying to figure out to what degree and
how how much and how much in relation to
uh the mutations of the coronavirus but
we've done all those things and yet we
could still get it and we could get
really sick and we could die so what do
you do well here we have something
that's an additional barrier it's not
something to justify getting no vaccine
imagine that your risk of death is 90
percent lower with the vaccine so okay
let's say the overall infection fatality
rate of covet is 0.8 why are we saying
0.8 well officially is 1.6 percent but
we have reason to believe that the real
number of infections is actually two or
even up to three times the number of
cases that are officially known so that
would put the infection fatality rate in
reality somewhere between 0.4 and 0.8
let's call it 0.8 okay so I get the
vaccine these are rough numbers I get
the vaccine and let's say that reduces
risk of death by 90 percent
I've gone now risk of death Wise from
0.8 to
0.08 I've reduced my risk of death
dramatically on an infection basis
if this pill then cuts it by 50 percent
you're talking about vaccine plus having
the coveted pill if you get sick as two
things together that would drop your
risk of death to 0.04 percent now for
the unvaccinated it also cuts it but it
remains 10 times higher if you if you
eliminate the vaccine layer of
protection the risk of death is 0.8
percent
if you get sick you take the pill that
drops it drops it to 0.4 percent me I
would prefer
0.04 as my risk of death rather than 0.4
percent that's just me you can do the
calculations you want but that's
sounding pretty good to me so this will
be submitted for emergency use
um and by the way I I'm I'm gonna get
ahead of one thing there are tons of
anti-vaxxers who have been saying I'm
not taking an experimental vaccine who
are already saying look the coveted pill
we knew it was coming I don't need the
vaccine because of the covid pill this
is just as experimental in the sense
that it doesn't yet even have emergency
use authorization if it gets it it will
have the status the vaccines have had
for a year only a month ago or so
roughly
was the Pfizer vaccine actually fully
approved so if your reason all along for
not taking the vaccine was it's
experimental in the sense that it's eua
emergency use approved
the best case scenario for the covet
pill that you might use to justify not
getting a vaccine is that it would have
that same emergency use authorization
status so these people are pathetic we
know that this to me is not an
alternative to vaccination it's if you
get vaccinated and you unfortunately get
sick anyway which is not super likely
right now but it does happen
statistically not super likely most of
the infections are in the unvaccinated
um you have another layer of protection
and that's a really really good thing
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping